I don't like
either of these guys.
I think --
Well, yeah.
Magicians -- Come on.
The worst.
They are --
Let's rank them.
What are they the wor--
Are they worse than
anybody else in show business,
or what's worse?
Morning deejays are worse.
Morning deejays, magicians.
Then magicians.
Where do mimes fit into that?
Mimes aren't
in show business.
Mimes are buskers.
I like that.
Well, I got to have
a little of this
to help me decide
this one.
I know what I'm thinking.
[ Lighter clicks,
water bubbles ]
Well, I don't know what
I'm thinking, so help me out.
All right.
There were some
critical moments in this case.
First of all, Dorian --
He admitted --
He said the word "borrowed."
He said "borrowed."
"I borrowed that shit."
Yeah.
He said it.
On the other hand...
[ Coughs ]
...Rob said that
he stole it from the other dude.
But then he said it's okay
'cause as soon
as it's published,
then you can just do it.
But if it was published,
then Dorian can just do it.
Exactly.
[ Both laugh ]
Oh, television.
5,000 bucks seems
like a lot to me.
To ask?
To say,
"Yeah, I want $5,000
'cause he took my trick."
Also,
I looked at these drawings.
Is that a $5,000 sketch
right there?
No.
The drawings
do not fully represent
what I saw Dorian doing.
The drawings have none
of Dorian's flair.
[ Lighter clicks ]
The other thing was, uh...
I don't remember
what the other thing was.
Wait, I'm the one
that's smoking, not you.
[ Both laugh ]